COMING OUT WITH VIDEO LATER IN
THE PROGRAM.
NOW, FIRST, ONE ANNOUNCEMENT, IF
ANYONE CARES, THE CROWDED FIELD
OF DEMOCRATIC RADICAL SOCIALISTS
JUST SHRUNK BY ONE.
HE DROPPED OUT OF THE RACE.
DID ANYBODY EVEN KNOW HE WAS IN
THE RACE?
NOW, FORMER RNC CHAIRMAN, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF.
TAMMY BRUCE.
LET'S GO THROUGH A LITTLE BIT OF
SLEEPY, CREEPY, CRAZY.
LET'S SEE.
HIS OWN WIFE, TAMMY, IF WE LOOK
AT IT, THAT WASN'T VERY
ENCOURAGING.
NOT GOOD.
HIS BRAIN SURGEON SAYS, NO, HIS
BRAIN IS OKAY.
CAN'T GO    GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR
DUNKIN' DONUTS WITHOUT A SLIGHT
INDIAN ACCENT.
BREAKING HIS STATE WAS A STATE.
FIRST TIME EVER YOU GOT AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO IS BRIGHT,
ARTICULATE, AND CLEAN.
IT'S STORYBOOK.
OR, POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS
TALENTED AS WHITE KIDS.
JOE, 30330.
I THINK THAT'S MY FAVORITE.
>> Tammy: YET.
HERE'S THE THING THAT ALSO I
THINK AMERICANS SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND DEMOCRATS
SHOULD BE APPALLED BY.
HE IS ACTUALLY IN THIS POSITION.
IT IS CLEAR HE SHOULD NOT BE.
AND YET, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
SORE DESTROYED AND BARACK OBAMA
DESTROYED IT IN HIS CULTIVATION
OF A CULT, THAT THEY ARE PUSHING
THIS MAN TO DO IT, BECAUSE THEY
DO BELIEVE THAT HE WOULD HAVE
MORE OF AN APPEAL THAN ALL OF
THE REST OF THEIR TALENTS.
SO THERE IS A POINT WHERE IT'S
BECOMING EMBARRASSING FOR THIS
MAN TO BE IN THIS POSITION.
HIS WIFE CLEARLY WANTS TO
SUPPORT HIM, BUT SHE OBVIOUSLY
IS ALSO WORRIED ABOUT THE PARTY.
BUT THEY CAN'T EVEN PUSH THROUGH
IT ON THEIR OWN.
I THINK THAT THAT TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW.
BUT THEN, ALSO, THAT THE
DEMOCRATS THEMSELVES.
IT ALSO HIGHLIGHTS THE CONTEMPT
THEY HAVE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND FOR THEIR OWN BASE.
THAT THERE'S NO REAL INTEREST IN
BEING THERE FOR EVERYONE IN THE
COUNTRY.
THEY LIE ABOUT WHO IS A RACIST.
THEY WANT TO DIVIDE AND CONQUER.
THEY ARE PROPOSING THINGS THAT
BERNIE SANDERS ADMITTED.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED ABOUT HOW MUCH
MEDICARE FOR ALL WOULD COUNT, HE
GOES OH, I DON'T HAVE THAT IN MY
POCKET.
NOBODY DOES.
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA, AND YET THEY
ARE PUTTING THEMSELVES IN THIS
POSITION, BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
THEIR OWN BASE IS IGNORANT.
THEY BELIEVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE DUMB.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAVE TO OFFER
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I HOPE THE REPUBLICANS
UNDERSTAND THIS, BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE REALLY TURNING
INTO A MAJOR PROBLEM FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SPEECH OF MY FAVORITE IS THIS
COMMENT.
TRUTH OVER FACTS.
BUT HE HAS EIGHT YEARS OF A
RECORD.
EIGHT YEARS OF ECONOMIC POLICY
FAILURE.
NO ONE HAS EVEN BEGUN TO TALK
ABOUT THAT.
>> WELL, THE OTHER PROBLEM IF
YOU ARE A CAMPAIGN MANAGER, YOU
HAVE TO WORRY THAT THESE ARE
JUST A PATTERN.
THE QUESTION IS IF THIS PATTERN
BECOMES AN ISSUE OF MENTAL
COMPETENCE, THAT IS QUOTE THE
ISSUE THAT'S GOING TO BRING
BRING --
>> Sean: ISN'T THAT ALREADY
HAPPENING?
>> IT IS HAPPENING.
THE MEDIA, I THINK AND SOME OF
THE FOLKS IN THE MEDIA THAT WANT
A MORE PROGRESSIVE CANDIDATE,
THEY WANT ELIZABETH WARREN.
THEY WANT KAMALA HARRIS.
THEY ARE GOING TO SWARM OVER
THIS ISSUE THAT'S PLAGUING
JOE BIDEN.
HERE'S THE OTHER PROBLEM FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, THOUGH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
OUTMANEUVERED THE DEMOCRATS ON
ONE OF THEIR SIGNATURE ISSUES,
WHICH IS THE SENTENCING.
ELIZABETH WARREN TALKING ABOUT
SENTENCING REFORM.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THAT THE
PERSON THEY HAVE TWO TO AGAINST
IS
HAS ACTUALLY DONE IT.
THEY HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM RIGHT
NOW.
NEWT GINGRICH WROTE A BOOK
CALLED REAL CHANGE MANY YEARS
AGO.
THE WHOLE PREMISE WAS THAT YOU
NEED TO FRAME THESE ISSUES IN
SUCH A WAY THAT 70% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AGREE WITH YOU
ON.
WHO DOESN'T AGREE WITH MOVING
THE CAPITAL FROM      TO JERUSAL
THE CAPITAL FROM      TO JERUSAM
THE CAPITAL FROM      TO JERUSA?
THE PRESIDENT HAS DELIVERED IT.
WHO DIDN'T AGREE THAT THE DEAL
WAS BAD?
>> Sean: REAL QUICK QUESTION.
WHO GETS THE NOMINATION AS OF
TONIGHT?
TAMMY.
SHE FOR A WHILE, I'LL TELL YOU.
IT WON'T BE JOE BIDEN.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT, I THINK THEY
THINK THAT KAMALA HARRIS IS
GOING TO HAVE IT.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
SEE TO YOU THINK?
BRYCE.
>> I THINK AYDIN WILL SQUEAK